I think it's so interesting
what you were saying earlier--
as a person who's been blind
your whole life-- not seeing
color, but also feeling and
recognizing the racial
injustices and how people-- all
of us who are seeing-- judge
each other by the color of our
skin. It must be very
interesting as a blind man for
race to play such a major role
in this country when for you it
truly isn't an issue 'cause you
--you can honestly say you
don't see color.
No--well, I do see color, but I
don't see it like that. I see
color in the spirit of the
person. And your spirit is
either good or bad. That's the
bottom line. You are living for
the perpetuation of life or you
are actually killing yourself
with the hate you have within.
That's what's up.
Okay, so where you sit now--
and you are, I know, a deeply
spiritual person, not just
religious, but a deeply
spiritual, feeling, conscious
person-- what do you think of
where we are as humanity and
how we're doing?
I think that people have gotten
so hung up in what they see
online, and, you know,
everyone's perpetuating hate
as opposed to love, and, you
know, it's a heartbreak for me,
it really is, because I think
you know, we have far much more
potential as human beings than
we're giving ourselves.
We're destroying the planet and
saying, "Oh, that's not real."
I--I don't know what people are thinking
about. You know, you are not
really privileged. Because when
you take from the almighty that
has given everything to you for
absolutely free and begin to
feel like, "Hey, well, that's--
"that's what I'm supposed to
have, this is how it's supposed
to be, and just for me,"
well, then, that's the
beginning of your death.
You know, you wrapped up your
video when you were speaking
about what was going on in the
world with an urgent plea.
In the words of John Lewis, you
were saying, "Do good trouble,"
and for me, good trouble is
bringing our nation,
this nation, back together
again. Together.
Yeah, and the way we do that is
to vote justice in and
injustice out, so--
Out.
Out. What do you wanna say-- I
am just sort of-- I'm baffled
by anyone who believes with the
state of our nation that their
vote doesn't matter. What do
you wanna say about that? When,
you know, you and I, in the
same age range, came up in a
generation where, you know,
people still were fighting for
the right to vote.
Listen, when you have a group
of people who actually plan to
kidnap a governor of a state...
Mm.
Because they feel a certain
kind of way, we are completely
off-beat.
Yeah.
You know, can you-- would you
share what you're trying to do
with the god that you
say you serve? Would you do
that? Would the god you serve
feel good about that from you?
It's bull tish.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
It really is. And so I just
feel that we have to... we have
to vote, you know, injustice
out and positive in.
So along with all the hundreds
of songs that you have written
for yourself, you've written
'em for other people.
We watched you earlier in the
year in that great special when
you were with Alicia Keys and
everybody and you played "Lean
On Me." what do you think we
can be leaning on right now?
What should we be leaning on?
Everybody loves that song.
Lean on the goodness in your
heart. Lean on that. Lean on--lean on
knowing that how you do today
will affect what will happen
to your children and their
children, and so forth on--
tomorrow. Lean on the fact that
you have to speak
and not be afraid.